how's it going Rick welcome back to some
more pixels
thank you bye welcome back to the man
with teddys I changed some gear I also
have this now this is pretty cool look
at this so we're back in an Orlando
there's a thing here that I missed
missed get it cos it's foggy it's
supposed to be the son of the final base
he's talking about my boobs
I literally have no idea what the hell
is going on why he knows he loses and
[ __ ] I forgot about that
hey what are you gonna do yeah I'm just
[ __ ] going for it I don't even give a
[ __ ] oh god you're ugly oh god I do a
lot of damage
don't you dare teleport don't your dad
tell about your stock done the light the
odd god dammit don't don't don't don't
don't do it
oh one more baby when you're in your
attic man that still hurts my feelings a
lot now your eyes his mind doesn't even
matter
yes damn what a party pooper I know I
can join his covenant or whatever but
why not kill people when you had the
chance that's what my mom always says oh
yes nothing nothing really that is a
[ __ ] big pain you man no don't touch
it oh that kind of suck and we're in the
painted world let's just follow wherever
oh this place is great
Oh paint fire check mines in these games
oh god what that [ __ ] are you aah
give me my soul all right I'm [ __ ] your
guy can't tell me our guide what's that
[ __ ] is happening rod oh god what is
that guy doing nah they're everywhere
I'm I gotta go over here somersault all
the way okay I found it
[Music]
one of his soul I didn't want anything
else you're looking at me like that for
what Oh God let me know God they have so
much help I'm alive I think no I'm dead
no I'm like that's what happens at the
fortified town girl drink drink
roll Oh still alive hello thank you oh
oh dude there's something down there
fight me huh what I don't like this look
at that
where's my bonfire this is an obviously
on track Oh God what no stop help no one
likes you guys no come do you guys
collect pokemons - that's awesome
is that a band fire what you guys have a
gangbang way it's my band fire wait wait
what's it really in here yes
wait what the [ __ ] what what what Ben
fire gang bangs in this game Ben fire
I'm not a sexual train alright let's go
down the hill hole not even cute skin it
q no oh god I hate the wheels don't be a
whale
I hate wheels they're like the worst
kind of people why do we even use wheels
what have they provided for society
nothing kind of this is a fake wall Oh
God not more wheels and excuse me to
enter X yeah yeah
oh just don't scare me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
they scare me I'm outta here
[ __ ] this place shake dance with me come
on girl
oh hey man woman oh [ __ ] she has friends
what that [ __ ] who's in that thing girl
friends are the worst one more baby from
behind baby hey baby
Wow Oh silence my fat nice look it's
probably just a giant poop or something
oh god I'm so sorry for calling you up
vomit okay let's see if we can get our
loot back sorry I'm just gonna get my
stuff and I'll be on my way thank ya
thank you
oh god oh god oh god come on I'm a
dragon tail gosh oh [ __ ]
I'm just gonna [ __ ] over here is that
okay Oh what the hell is I like I can do
that [ __ ] hair like
but you're not alone man I'm gonna cut
your nails now oh he is taking damage
all right well that no no no back that
is exactly what I wanted to do charge
never mind
oh yeah you're basically [ __ ] now man
yes oh yeah
high five oof what happens in here now
don't dodge a hagwon rod stock don't
make me pass on no she should never said
why I'm quite sons myself we wait Fabian
okay [ __ ] off what are you stop changing
wait with your eyes Oh
what did I say what did I say god damn
never learn I've been here before
long ago scheisse that's what you gave
I'm a drag ow ow ow ow
I'd really hurry out stop stop please
stop is it boss time fight or what bring
it whoa hi
ooh a nice tail on that lady can I cut
it off ha
[Music]
all right cool now watch that's sneaky
kill bah
she's there I see oh never mind
yes got you now [ __ ]
oh did I kind of retail I did awesome
Asha I just died well that was fun let's
do that again
I got twins from her what happened don't
do it there's a life worth living you
can go on a diet I promise it will be
okay god damn Tatum X wagon is yolo ways
yeah all right I like that place that
was pretty cool I proposed I tried
everything I could and I can't get
internet to work on my own my
playstation so I can't download the DLC
i bought the prepare to die edition
which has the dlc but my save file is
not on it so i have to replay the entire
game to play the dlc we're not gonna
have time for that so unfortunately
we're gonna have to finish the game it's
kind of crazy how you say that
unfortunately we have to finish the game
that just shows that it's a [ __ ]
awesome game in my opinion but yeah
let's let's do it together breasts maybe
in the future I'll figure out a way to
do a DLC I personally really want to
check it out so it's [ __ ] cool man
this place looks so [ __ ] cool I never
played a game that continues to amaze me
look at this so [ __ ] cool kill of the
first flame and it's full of ashes
everywhere all right here we go I'm not
supposed to have this weapon please
change oh God alright dude I don't have
time for you man oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is
a very bad first try
oh god he's so good calm down can a man
like goddamnit what a [ __ ]
where's first try ever he's just
chilling here like all day that's what
you do come on got gems I wanted some in
a period
oh no he'll you know he'll he'll he'll
oh baby baby it's a wild world no no no
stop grabbing back if you would so
stupid dad I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
one more poke who's gonna poke first
break baby break it down now here we go
okay okay well I guess I guess we're
gonna take over his job or whatever
let's do it hell yeah
yeah look so sexy losing
have you ever seen a dragon with tits
before no you haven't
I am the [ __ ] Sun [ __ ] they M Oh
huh I never ever thought we would
actually reach this point I bet a lot of
you didn't think so either but we did it
together despite me sucking but the help
of you brothers we we managed to do it
it's been an epic epic journey I don't
think I ever put so much time into a
playthrough ash this one
maybe I'm Nisha but still mad this is
pretty crazy I I think I spent just like
a hundred over a hundred hours just
editing these videos and I think I
played the game for like a hundred hours
- it's it's [ __ ] crazy but I loved it
all the way through this game just blew
my mind after the second boss I knew for
sure we were gonna finish it because I
just never felt this feeling before of
accomplishment from a game like it was
like a drug I was like I want this more
this is so cool ever since I started my
channel in YouTube I've just been blown
away by games I wouldn't normally play
like I played amnesia which I would
never I play before and experience being
so scared for the first time that just
blew my mind like it was so I thought
that was so cool and that just was like
the most amazing thing and then we
played Walking Dead and I never felt so
emotionally attached to a game before
and that was like blew my mind too
because I thought that was so cool and
and and then we did Dark Soul and I've
never been a so amazed by the gameplay
like I don't I know there's a story but
I didn't even know the [ __ ] story
and I always thought that the reason to
finish a game is because he won you want
to see how the story goes but
really I finished the game because I
wanted to play play the game I wanted
the gameplay and that's never happened
before and that was just amazing I love
this game we blew my mind
the the scenery the design of the
monsters everything this is amazing the
sound is amazing what more could you
want from a game I don't know I'm just
really impressed by it I'm so glad I
picked it up regardless I just want to
thank you both so much for being with me
in this series it wasn't really a series
- it was a serious but it wasn't really
a let's play or a playthrough it was
more like a montage through or something
the the reason why is because it takes
so many hours for to finish this game at
least on your first playthrough and
since I didn't spend a lot of time just
replaying areas and stuff like that I
know people who wouldn't want to watch
it I just knew I really wanted to play
this game no matter what and I wouldn't
have time to do it on my spare time
because I have very little spare time so
I knew I had to make it into videos and
I know the only way for for what the
majority to actually watch the videos
was asleep if I added it added the [ __ ]
out of it and that's what I did only for
that reason I know a lot some people who
were kind of like I shouldn't add it so
much but I I really think that's it for
me that I've done it because I know most
people would have ignored these series
otherwise but yeah and I'm so glad it
worked out I was I can't tell you about
saw a fan they worked out there spend
gains before what I really wanted really
really wanted to play and most people
didn't like it so I have to drop it and
Nina Cunha for example I really wanted
to finish that game but most people
didn't like it so I couldn't finish it
and III don't have much spare time
Bridge it's the sad truth I put most
time into making videos I don't play
that much by myself very very very very
very little but every time I get left I
spend with my like spending with friends
or my girlfriend so I'm so happy I got
the game
so there there you go that's the whole
story behind it thank you both so much
for being supportive during this series
it really meant a lot to me in general
thanks for being a bro I rose are the
coolest I'll see you in the next series
whatever we're gonna make I'm sure it's
gonna be just as epic as always here
comes an epic brofist for you stay
awesome bros love you
[Music]
you